tout est avec nous ce soir pour en
parler isabelle bonnet porte parole de
lutte ouvrière à marseille bonsoir
isabelle bonnet merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés hacène hamouche président du
collectif marseillais trop jeune pour
mourir bonsoir à senna mot merci d'être
avec nous emmanuel macron qui est arrivé
1 sous les huées hier on a vu marseille
l'heure ce matin à l'école un u est
également est ce que vous pensez qu'il a
tout de même marqué des points
aujourd'hui aux yeux de la population
avec ses discours et ses annonces
isabelle bonnet
bah écoutez moi j'ai l'impression
d'entendre la même chose qui à cinq ans
pour parrot monte plus en arrière avec
le plan de manuel valls qui était avec
un gros comité interministériel c'était
le même défilé de ministres avaient et
cetera et c'est vrai que c'est du vent
rick ce sont tes promesses c'est vrai
ils ce sont des engagements concrètement
la vie dans les quartiers populaires
elle a pas changé les logements sans
dégrader de plus en plus dégradée on a
connu depuis le drame de la rue
d'aubagne mais en a eu un autre cet été
aux flamands avec trois morts à la suite
d'un incendie dans un immeuble qui était
en grande partie squatté c'est vrai j'ai
entendu vos témoignages c'est vrai que
la vie elle devient
insupportable pour les anciens pour les
jeunes compact boulot pour les anciens
qui sont maintenus dans des quartiers où
il n'y a pas de transports pour les
jeunes effectivement qui gagne en une
journée ce que leurs parents peuvent
s'échiner des fois en ménage tôt le
matin a gagné au bout de plusieurs
semaines donc écouter le mal dont on est
en train de crever aujourd'hui c'est le
chômage de masse c'est sûr maj de masse
qui ravage les quartiers et là j'ai
absolument rien entendu par rapport à ça
alors il ya quelques annonces on va en
parler dans quelques instants avant cela
vous assène amour
pour vous il a marqué des points ce
président isabelle mon bonnet nous dit
voilà on a entendu ça maintes et maintes
fois ça n'a pas beaucoup impressionné
manifestement vous avez été séduit par
une partie du discours du président et
par ces annonces surtout
au vu de la situation on a envie d'y
croire parce que effectivement et une
nouvelle majorité municipale dans la
ville il faut pas oublier il ya un
contexte à marseille le président de la
république est venu écouter des
habitants qui étaient en grande
inquiétude cette parole là était
finalement la plus marquante de son
déplacement ensuite il annonce une
cinquantaine de médiateurs
supplémentaires et d'éducateurs il
annonce une compagnie de crs pas sûr que
ce soit la bonne solution pour qu'on a
déjà eu l'expérience ou la main sous
l'oeil l'autorité nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque ministre d'alors alors qui ça
n'a pas produit ses effets réellement
donc aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire tout
ce qui vient d'annoncer ça reste encore
au stade des annonces il ya aussi les
grandes dispositif dont il a évoqué qui
existe déjà dans la ville donc ils
crient rien en les annonçant et les
ajuste il s'en est juste aproprié un
certain nombre de projets et a pris à
toutes les annonces de financement
notamment sur la rénovation des écoles
et et de ce fameux commissariat lé don
en avant depuis quelques mois déjà j'ai
l'impression quand même que l'exercice
du président la république aujourd'hui
ilves totalement le fait que dans huit
mois il ya une élection présidentielle
ça veut dire une arrière pensée
électorale clairement isabelle bonnet il
dit tout de même emmanuel macron
collectivement on n'a pas été à la
hauteur c'est un aveu d'échec tout de
même il ya quelque chose qui va changer
selon vous avec ce président et ses
annonces on va parler ce carnet de
chèques sortie allègrement aujourd'hui
où comme le dit
votre interlocuteur ce soir finalement
on a un président en campagne électorale
et ça s'arrête là
non mais ça fait plus d'un an et demi
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
que de temps en temps comme ça il fait
un petit acte de mea culpa on n'a pas
fait assez on n'a pas été assez loin on
n'a pas assez at on entendu les gens
dans les quartiers populaires et puis
qu'est-ce qui change concrètement
regarder rien de par rapport à la
situation catastrophique des hôpitaux
puisque les s'est rendu à l'hôpital de
la timone à marseille cet après midi
qu'est ce qui a changé concrètement
combien il ya eu une embauche en quoi le
travail des soignants et puis de tout le
personnel hospitalier qui est autour des
soignants a été améliorée
cc on est dans la même situation qu'il
ya un an et demi et les soignants épuisé
voir arriver les vagues les unes après
les autres sans que rien ne change si ce
n'est le coup de bâton supplémentaire
avec en plus la culpabilisation avec
l'obligation vaccinale je pourrais vous
parler aussi des écoles puisque je suis
enseignante ça fait combien de temps
qu'on dit que les écoles de marseille
c'est la honte de la république
donc il suffit pas de le dire qu'est ce
qu'on met en avant pour ça change et ben
moi je n'ai rien entendu de ce qui me
semble indispensable pour faire changer
la vie dans ces quartiers créer de
l'emploi massivement par tous recrutés
ces jeunes recrutés pour pouvoir
soulager ceux qui travaillent durement
dans les entreprises et qui n'en peuvent
plus pour pouvoir soulager dans les
transports dans dans dans la santé dans
l'éducation
et puis surtout regarder tous les
emplois qui manquent ne fût-ce que pour
reconstruire toutes ces écoles ne fût ce
que pour vous construire ces quartiers
qui sont à l'abandon depuis des années
comme la cité qu'il a pu visiter il faut
mettre des moyens massifs mais il faut
surtout embauches et il faut surtout que
les gens il est du boulot qui est des
perspectives que cette société se soit
pas tu viens de tels quartiers t'as pas
d'issue d'autre que le trafic de drogue
d'autre que de tomber dans la
délinquance ça devient plus acceptable
par isabelle bonnet tout de même à ce
qui met en avant emmanuel macron voilà
c'est plus de 2 1 milliards sur la table
des nouveaux euro des nouveaux chèques
on rappelle quand même hein on va pas
tous faire appeler parce qu'il y en a eu
beaucoup d investissement marseille en
1995 un double 6 milliards qui avait été
dans des pensées dans le projet
euroméditerranée françois lamy lui aussi
1 lors du dernier mandat de françois
hollande avait investi massivement là
encore plus d'un milliard qui va être
investi c'est vrai qu'à saint amour on
se pose la question vous par exemple sur
le terrain vos associations vous envoyer
la couleur de cet argent parce que c'est
autant d'argent voilà qui creuse la
dette est ce que concrètement on le voit
sur le terrain
alors on parle en ont bien évidemment il
ya une bm qui aiment manque de
visibilité des politiques publiques dans
nos territoires et dans nos cités c'est
dans la vie de tous les jours quand on
voit la mascarade auquel on a assisté
hier d'une cité qui se fait nettoyés
juste avant l'arrivée du président de la
république ce sont des choses qui ne
devraient pas arriver le président la
république devrait se rendre compte du
quotidien des habitants dès son arrivée
dans les quartiers en revanche de
noircir est pas autant
pardon ni varrault cet argent cet argent
aujourd'hui il ya dix ans il ya
plusieurs s'il ya plusieurs canaux c'est
à dire qu'il ya le bâti la rénovation
des écoles primaires si l'engagement a
été pris avec le paysan la république je
le vois pas comment est ce qui pourrait
aujourd'hui faire autrement que
d'essayer de débloquer ces fonds donc je
pense que il tiendra promesse après je
suis pas son porte parole et j'espère
qu'il tiendra promesse et après il ya
tout l'investissement dans le vivant et
là je pense qu'il n'est pas le seul même
si c'en est l'un des acteurs aussi à
devoir m excusez moi l'expression le
paquet sur le vivant et donc la présence
humaine de moyens de service public dans
nos cités il ya le département et à la
métropole et à la vident la ville dans
une moindre mesure parce qu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui les compétences de la
ville de marseille sont de plus en plus
réduite mais par exemple pour la
fracture des transports qui existe entre
les quartiers nord et le célé et il son
coeur de ville quand on sait que partir
du centre-ville de marseille pour jeunes
les quartiers nord c'est au bas mot une
heure et demie de transport c'est une
honte donc ces inégalités destin avec
ces inégalités territoire avec tout cela
ça forme un cocktail qui est explosif
donc aujourd'hui cet argent là elle
n'arrive pas encore en pied d'immeuble
elle n'arrive pas encore dans les poches
des associations qui pourraient faire ce
travail humain
avec les habitants il ya un manque aussi
je le dis de présence publique et tout
ça malheureusement vous avez raison on
n'en a pas vu la couleur à l'heure où
nous parlons oui parce que cet argent là
je vous parle d'un argent vieux de
quelques dizaines d'années déjà on va on
va regarder ces chiffres assez édifiant
qui résume aussi malheureusement
marseille un pas que mes mais beaucoup
regardé 1,5 milliard d'euros de dettes
deux fois plus élevé que la moyenne des
villes 61 millions d'euros gaspillés
dans la gestion du personnel ça rapport
de la cour des comptes budget 13
millions pour l'investissement les
impôts représentent deux tiers des
recettes 53% de les ménages non
imposables
isabelle bonnet une question peut-être
qui va vous paraître un peu mais il est
simple mais pourquoi est ce si compliqué
à marseille finalement
non c'est pas compliqué il suffit en
effet de demander à la population et
c'est très bien les associations comme
celle
dans laquelle milite ce monsieur mais en
a des tas d'associations et tu m'aimes
dans les quartiers il ya des il ya des
gens qui sont au contact des jeunes de
tous ceux qui sont en difficulté il ya
eu toute une salle solidarité pardon qui
s'est mise en place pour pouvoir
subvenir au moment dé confinement
successifs y compris à des problèmes
comme simplement se nourrir au quotidien
qu organiser le ravitaillement qui ont
organisé des tas de choses non ce qui
manque c'est la volonté politique de
prendre de l'argent mais moi quand je
vous parle d'argent comprenez vous
parlez d'un milliard rien ce qui a été
donné aux grands groupes au titre de
toutes les aides par l'état ça se
chiffre en centaines de milliards donc
votre milliards c'est une espèce de
gouttes d'eau déjà je sais pas dans
quelle poche chaque tombe si elle tente
dans la poche des promoteurs immobiliers
qui construisent du logement cher là où
ce qui manque le plus c'est du logement
dans les quartiers populaires adapté à
des revenus modestes moi ça me fait une
belle jambe un que lier des hôtels
flambant neuf qui est des résidences
luxueuses à marseille parce qu'il ya ça
aussi à marseille non le problème c'est
qu'il faut orienter justement largement
en fonction des besoins de la population
laborieuse en fonction des besoins qui a
dans les quartiers populaires rénover
les écoles c'est une chose si on
n'embauche pas le nombre de tata comme
on dit à marseille c'est à dire d'agents
des écoles on pouvoir faire fonctionner
les cantines normalement elles sont un
pur 50 enfants dans une ville comme
marseille c'est beaucoup moins que dans
bien d'autres villes de d'importance
moindre donc voilà elles sont là aussi
les inégalités c'est aussi justement en
termes d'emploi d'encadrement et ça
honnêtement j'en ai pas entendu un mot
là de la part de toutes les annonces qui
ont été faites j'ai pas entendu ce matin
comme lancker disait qu'on allait
recruter
dans les écoles alors que pas plus tard
qu'il ya deux jours même les chefs
d'établissements étaient dans le
rectorat d'aix-marseille pour dénoncer
le sodat mans de l'académie en termes de
moyens humains donc non temps quand on
met pas sur la table des dizaines de
milliards qu'on a prélevé dans les
dividendes de ces grands groupes
capitalistes qui se gavent ils sortent
encore plus riches de cette crise mois
ce qui m'indigne c'est pour ça que je
suis en colère c'est pas parce que je
noircis les choses parce que moi je me
bats tous les jours pour qu'elle change
les choses mais c'est parce que sam
indigne que les riches soient sortis
encore plus riches de cette crise
sanitaire et les pauvres encore plus
pauvres
donc quand est ce qu'on va inverser ça
il faut qu'on se décide à taper dans la
poche des riches oui pour financer
effectivement tous les besoins utiles à
la population des quartiers populaires
alors la cena mauvais éléments sur le
plan de l'emploi
isabelle bonnet on parle depuis le début
effectivement emmanuel daumas qu'on lui
souhaite mettre en oeuvre je cite un
guichet unique des initiatives dans
bausch de formation des jeunes et de
programme d'alternance 1 je le lis parce
que c'est vrai que c'est assez flou tout
ça pas grand chose
comme mesure sur le trafic de drogue est
ce que
c'est quoi la priorité pour vous plutôt
la lutte contre le trafic de drogue ont
effectivement on contre le chômage ou
les deux
non mais moi je pense que le plan qui
doit être aujourd'hui développé pour la
ville de marseille ces deux êtres un
plan j'ai envie de dire ceux requis ce
qui interviennent sous tous ses aspects
de la vie au quotidien des habitants il
ya la question de la sécurité évidemment
il ya la question des effectifs de
policiers à la question clairement des
moyens des forces de l'ordre là on le
voit lui ce qu'il propose le président
de la république et ex ministre de
l'intérieur c'est donc le renfort des
caméras de surveillance moi je le dis
sur toutes les mesures qu'il a annoncées
aujourd'hui peu d'entre elles m'ont
convaincu pour une raison simple c'est
qu'on sait très bien que les annonces
des deux cents policiers dont il fait
état il ya une réalité auquel on va être
confronté c augmentent d'effectifs de la
police et comment est ce qu'il va
pouvoir d'une région à l'autre déployé
des unités de police dans la ville de
marseille donc il ya ça mais il faut pas
et décidé alors le lutter contre le
chômage des jeunes
investir les quartiers avec des
médiateurs et des éducateurs de rue
toutes ces choses là sont des pour
l'instant au stade des belles paroles à
mettre au compte du président la
république mais je pense qu'il a bien en
quelques heures cernés quels étaient les
difficultés dans l'eau dans nos
quartiers et nous associatif on a répété
donc aux oreilles des consignes et aux
oreilles de l'entourage du président de
la république et je pense qui s'est
aussi servi nos mots pour raconter la
vie dans son discours présidentiel sauf
qu'aujourd'hui entre je vous le dis
encore une fois même s'il s'est défendu
de vouloir faire de la politique
politicienne pendant cette visite il ya
quand même les paroles et des actes et
j'ai l'impression qu'on est plutôt au
stade des paroles et quand on perd on
promet autant d'argent en aussi peu de
temps donc je me demande comment est ce
que réellement tout ça va être mis en
oeuvre et je je je vois que vous avez
montré tout à l'heure un tableau dans
votre émission qui reprenait les
finances l'état des finances de la ville
de marseille c'est vrai cette ville a
été mal gérée pendant des années et ces
années là elles se sont ce manque de
gestion a eu lieu sous les années godin
il faut aussi le rappeler dans votre
émission bon diagnostic peut-être mais
pas le bon remède si je résume
plus ou moins votre pensée à tous les
deux merci isabelle bonnet merci
également à scène à nous d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt français